[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the optimus g pro from lg it's lg's
first entry into the phablet game or the
five inch or larger smartphone form
factor category
and they were smart and took a lot of
cues from samsung's very popular galaxy
note 2 and then they took some design
improvements and some spec bumps and
some overall hardware upgrades and some
software tweaks and basically turned
into the most accurate thing that we're
going to see to the galaxy note 3 which
isn't out yet but this is probably the
closest thing we're going to see to that
for a while so without any further ado
let's take a closer video look at the lg
optimus g pro so this is a big phone no
doubt just like the galaxy note 2 it has
a lot of similarities with its samsung
counterpart but then each aspect is
slightly improved just slightly so you
can start with the build both phones are
made of plastic but the optimus g pro on
one hand feels a little bit more compact
in the hand it has a slightly narrower
body while maintaining that 5.5 inch
display and that's because the bezel is
twice as thin as on the note 2. the
optimus also has a removable back of
course which reveals a slightly larger
battery coming in at
3140 milliamp hours a tiny bit larger
than the one in the note 2 and this
thing lasts just as long on a charge i'm
talking full weekend road trip companion
this is a road warrior just like the
note also behind that back cover are of
course the sim card tray any micro sd
card slot for expandable storage and up
top is the slightly unimpressive speaker
probably the most unimpressive part of
the whole phone it's a bit small and it
could easily be covered up with a single
finger but you also get the 13 megapixel
camera up there which we'll get to in
just a second other than that though
just about everything about the optimus
gpro's build quality is nearly as good
as it gets on a phone of the size i mean
we've never seen a phablet that's made
of metal so obviously this is as well
built as a phone that you can probably
get from top to bottom in that form
factor and also the home button that
doubles as a notification led is a nice
touch the led colors are great now
flanking that home button are the menu
and back buttons but lg's just flip them
around so they're the opposite of all
those samsung devices out there so it
took me a little while to get used to
but there's the back button on the left
and the menu button on the right
i guess if you're going to change
something just for the sake of changing
it it might as well be something small
like that but all around this phone
feels about the same as the galaxy note
2 just slightly different in a lot of
ways and then you get to turning it on
and the first thing you notice even more
than that display is lg's weird lock
screen totally blows my mind every time
i use it but there it is and yeah the
biggest difference once you turn it on
is lg's display here we have a 5.5 inch
1080p full hd super ips display as we
know the galaxy note 2 has a 720p
display so this display has excellent
color reproduction clarity sharpness
viewing angles brightness everything
about it it's a very good panel and i
love the bezel i love the fact that it's
so thin it really makes this phone's
display stand out it seems like that's
the highlight of this phone and it
should be it's probably one of the best
aspects of it i was initially concerned
about the panel's impact on battery life
thinking that a different display would
have a very different battery life but
like i said before this phone had no
problem lasting two full days on a
battery charge as normally used so
that's just a breeze to handle anyway
the next biggest difference and the
biggest thing you'll notice about the
optimus g pro is lg's skin on top of
android 4.1.2
lg next to motorola and maybe oppo have
probably the most unconventional far out
stock android skin of any phone
manufacturer today obviously the lock
screen is one big change but you'll
notice just about everything about this
phone outside of the lock screen has
changed too you can see where they took
hints from the note 2 the default time
and weather widget is an obvious one not
too hard to see the similarities there
and also instead of samsung's multiple
windows running next to each other lg
has cue slide which is one app that can
be toggled transparent on top of the
other lg also has a tabbed menu
structure that lets you swipe through
the menus thank goodness but they also
let you switch between the tabbed and
just a full list of all the settings
the default is the tab structure but i
kind of like that they give you the
choice to just get that full list if you
don't really want to drill down overall
though it's android and you can
customize it to look like basically
whatever you want you can make it look
however you feel but a lot of the
elements of lg's custom skin like the
credit notification panel for example
are unavoidable like every single time
you pull down the notification panel
it's half full of things like you know
toggles and a slider for brightness and
a whole bunch of different stuff there
are also a ton of pre-installed apps
like more than any other phone i've ever
used now i'm using the 18-t version here
but obviously there's not going to be
tons of pre-installed apps on the
international version but there is
definitely a lot of stuff that came on
the phone but overall i like that this
phone is such a great performer it's
that's to be expected of course with the
qualcomm snapdragon 600 quad core
processor inside obviously one of the
best processors you can put in a phone
but yeah this thing is a great performer
and it constantly surprised me with how
snappy and smooth the experience was
using it probably a little bit snappier
than the galaxy note 2 so that's
definitely a good sign but overall this
is definitely an lg phone lg really made
it an lg experience and you can see how
many cues they took from samsung both in
the software and the hardware of course
the note 2 has one of the best 8
megapixel cameras in any smartphone but
the optimus g pro shooter is 13
megapixels so it takes slightly more
detailed shots thanks to that extra
resolution but nothing all that crazy
it's also not very contrasty so you lose
a bit of that dynamic range and it's not
quite as vibrant as samsung's color and
photos and videos from this camera you
also don't get the same interface or the
same crazy features that samsung throws
in there but overall it's not a bad
camera at all and you won't be
disappointed with it actually the 1080p
videos it takes are really quite good in
any kind of light and i found myself
taking pretty much everything in full
auto because auto does a great job on
this phone so props to lg for that so
yeah if i had to describe the optimus g
pro in one word it would be lg because
this phone is so lg it's full of lg in
every imaginable way everywhere that
there's room for an lg touch you can
expect an lg touch and these you know
these lg touches are all shots
attempting to one-up the galaxy note 2.
and i love that it's the competition
that drives us forward and this is
basically the galaxy note 2.5 so in the
end the optim's g pro is an excellent
phone definitely lg's best yet it's
great in all the same ways that the
galaxy note 2 is great you can consider
it a small side step or even a slight
upgrade from the galaxy note 2. again we
don't know what the galaxy note 3 is
going to look like but this is probably
your best bet for an upgrade from the
note 2 if you want to stay in that
phablet form factor and even get a
slightly better phone you know we have a
bigger battery you have a higher
resolution camera you have a 1080p
display you have a whole bunch of
improvements in here so this is lg's
best phone yet i would definitely
recommend it if you're into the lg skin
i personally wouldn't go for it as my
daily driver just because some of the
animations don't quite feel right some
of the software i'm not a fan of and i
don't happen to be a huge fan of the
looks of lg's skin on top of android
that could change soon but for now it's
a good phone on the hardware front and
it's getting there with the software
either way that's been it thank you for
watching this review of the optimus gpro
hope you enjoyed if you want to see more
videos like this definitely hit that
subscribe button below and there's also
a thumbs up button if you liked the
video either way like i said thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next video
peace
[Music]
you